hello everyone and welcome to an
absolutely incredible game from round
two of this year's Tata steel Masters
Edition uh we have Vincent kymer versus
Magnus Carlsen so this is the As Good As
It Gets for any player I guess
especially a young player who is uh yeah
extremely strong but still has to uh
work on his rating a little bit he he
already uh broke the 2700 barrier uh
he's now at 26 uh 96 but yeah you have
the white piece against Magnus Carson in
a classical tournament in one of the
most prestigious classical tournaments
of the year uh this is uh I mean this is
as good as it gets you you will not get
a finer challenge than this okay maybe
playing with the black pieces would be a
finer challenge but I mean this is
absolutely spectacular spectacular and
those of you who have been following the
world rapid and Blitz Championship know
that Vincent was extremely close at
winning uh even the world Rapids
Championship he got second place behind
Magnus Carlsen and even in Blitz uh he
did incredibly well I think he got like
12th or maybe the 13th but I mean still
absolutely incredible but this is
classical his opponent is the highest
ever rated classical player in the world
Magnus Carlsen let's see what happens uh
the game starts with uh Vincent playing
Pawn to D4 uh we have Knight to F6 by
Magnus C for G6 Knight to C3 and now
Pawn to D5 Magnus goes for the
groomfield defense and okay could be a
very a very flashy game could be a very
slow game but it's uh probably not going
to be a boring game as Magnus in order
to reach that unattainable goal of 2900
classical rating he has to continuously
win games and in order to do that he
can't really play weird stuff he has to
play very solid stuff but again a very
solid stuff that gives chances for both
sides so uh you know the the better
player will prevail so Knight to F3 with
Bishop to G7 and now there are many uh
ways uh one could challenge the groom
fill the face uh defense most popularly
C captures and the five Queen the B3 can
be played E3 can be played Bishop to F4
can be played uh Vincent goes for Bishop
to G5 I think uh like the third most
popular option uh we have knighted the
E4 Magnus challenges the bishop and now
the main move here is C capture Sun D5
but Vincent goes for Bishop back to F4
uh Knight captures on c3b captures and
pawn to C6 now and this is a very very
rare move usually you will see something
like a pawn all the way not that pawn
all the way to C5 or castles here but C6
is incredibly rare it has been played
maybe some 10 times in top level games
but one of the times it was played it
was played by Magnus Carlsen uh in his
game against Hikaru Nakamura in the BL
Tournament of uh 2012 so uh some 11
years ago and okay Ponte E3 uh we have
Castles by Magnus and now in the game
Nakamura played C captress on D5 uh that
game that we've mentioned but here we
have Queen to B3 by Vincent uh and now
there still are a few more games that
reach this position Magnus goes Queen to
A5 and now Bishop to E2 and there is a
game where Knight to D7 was played by
Magnus goes for D captures and C4 and it
is now already as of move tender we have
a completely new game so Bishop captures
and C4 no reason not to do this Knight
to D7 and now uh Vincent has to figure
out how to go about this you can see
that the Queen Bishop battery here
uh goes after that F7 pawn and the one
might get the idea of going Knights to
G5 how would black reply to this let's
say in ig5 uh magnets can just play E6
and okay the Knight really has no
business being on uh on G5 but there's
also the very tricky Pawn to E5 and if
Vincent is not prepared for this and the
Magnus definitely is as he's playing
this uh you would really have to spend a
burn time calculating this for example
Bishop captures an F7 check King to h8
now D captures an E5 but now Knight
captures on E5 and here how do you play
this let's say castles Now Pawn to H6
and what do you do about the bishop here
hanging you have to capture an E5 so
Bishop captures Queen captures on E5 and
now let's say Knight F3 attacks the
queen and queen to F6 and you now attack
the bishop Bishop has to move back and
now you either keep the tension maybe
try to go for the attack you do have the
semi-open file for your rook and queen
you have the bishop pair you have the
other work so maybe it's possible to
cause damage here but also you could
just claim the C3 Pawn let's say
captures captures Rook to C1 Bishop to
F6 and you play this position with um
with having the bishop pair having a
three to one Pawn advantage on the queen
side uh it would be it would be very
tricky to play this so okay it's a nice
move but uh I mean it doesn't really
gain you anything at best it gives you
an equal end game against Magnus
Crossing with him having the bishop pair
not the the greatest day so Bishop to G5
instead Vincent forces now Magnus to
decide how he will defend the E7 Pawn
but luckily it's not that problematic
Magnus plays Pawn to B5 first kicks away
one of the attackers of the F7 pawn
bishop back to E2 and now he just
defends the E7 Pawn With The Rook so
here are Vincent castles Knight the B6
and now uh of course the Knight Canal
also come to D5 so Pawn to E4 and Bishop
to E6 attacking the queen and the
grabbing full control over that C4
square and also you have to be careful
the the A2 Pawn might be hanging that's
very unlikely but you know better to
keep an eye on that so Queen to C2 and
now Pawn to C5 getting rid of this a
backward C Pawn uh now you are putting
more pressure on the center and you are
inviting Vincent to advance his Pawn to
D5 which is exactly what Vincent does
you could also play D captures on C5 uh
sort of winning upon and creating a pass
Pawn but then Knight the A4 comes that's
attacking the C3 Pawn then the Rooks
would come to the C file and it's again
not spectacular so Vincent does go for
D5 and now Bishop to G4 uh we have
Bishop to D2 as the the C3 Pawn is
hanging now you have to defend this
otherwise Magnus just gets a pass C Pawn
so uh Bishop to D to you uh maybe a
slightly more precise Rook to C1
defending it like this as uh now if E6
you can just play D6 and you don't have
to worry about moves like Rook to d8 you
still have control over that and maybe
in some lines even Bishop to E7 is
possible so who knows but Vincent goes
Bishop to D2 and now Magnus just plays
Pawn to E6 and now D6 would be a bit
over optimistic rookie to d8 and there
really are no good ways to defend this
Pawn like E5 you can just eliminate the
Knight and pick up the pawn uh not not
the best so here Rook a to B1 Vincent
goes after the B5 Pawn First and Magnus
defends it by advancing his Pawn to C4
and also this uh frees up some squares
for for the Knight for example Knight to
a for the C5 can uh bring the Knight all
the way to D3 once the position clears
up a little bit so D captures an E6 by
Vincent Rook captures and now Knights
the D4 offering a trade of Bishops but
also attacking the rook and Magnus just
plays Bishop captures on E2 and the
problem now is that if you go for the
Rook you're just gonna blunder the game
of course now F captures an E6 and if
Rook moves doesn't really matter where
you move the Rook just to Bishop to D3
and that's it Queen to B2 you're gonna
win back material and after Queen
captures on B1 you will be up a full
night so after Bishop captures I need
two Knight captures I need two wins into
wins back the piece and the pawn to A6
Magna solidifies here and now he will uh
probably uh improve the position of his
Knight and then move the queen and then
continue pushing create a pass Pawn on
the queen side and this is his game plan
so Knights the D4 the Vincent also
claims a beautiful Square for his Knight
it um I mean of course the bishop will
not capture and otherwise it's very hard
to oppose that Knight so Rook back to E8
and now Rook after E1 we have Knight the
A4 by Magnus now putting more pressure
on that C3 Pawn but also just
re-maneuvering the knights to D3 Vincent
goes Knight to C6 and now Queen to C7
attacking the Knight and now we have
Knight the B4 preparing to bring the
knights the D5 uh Knight the C5
preparing to go for Knight to D3 3 and
now Knight to D5 and it seems that okay
Magnus will get a beautiful D3 square
but Vincent also gets something in
return the D5 square is also pretty
spectacular the problem is Magnus now
plays Queen to C6 and it's not easy to
find a move for Vincent uh how do you
how do you how do you handle this uh the
problem is uh I'm not going to tell you
what the problem is you're gonna figure
out what the problem is but let's say
you you play something like F3 you don't
want your E4 Pawn to be uh under attack
because then a knight can just capture
and queen captures and D5 can come uh
Knight to D3 can be played you attack
the rook and the once uh The Rook moves
uh even moves like Queen captures and D5
are in the position that's how Wild this
position is e captures Rook captures and
okay you have a queen but it's
absolutely useless uh the the Knight
controlling D1 and C1 squares uh this
Rook really has no no squares and what
are you gonna do with the dark Square
Bishop for example Rook F1 Bishop to f8
You're Now gonna bring the bishop flip
over to this diagonal let's say queen D1
Bishop C5 checking each one and now
you're gonna double up on the E file
there's no move here for white you can
just suffer that that's that's all you
can do here so instead after Queen to C6
wins and says all right that doesn't
look all that spectacular uh he might go
back with knights the B4 that's also an
option but he goes Bishop to G5 he says
all right uh you do what you have to I'm
threatening Knight to the E7 check to
win material here it's also the position
from the thumbnail feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the
absolute best move for Magnus uh while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh uh brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Knight captures on e4 that's how you do
it you give up the exchange but you're
gonna win uh so much more in return so
Vincent has to go for it there's nothing
better Knights the E7 with check uh
Magnus plays Rook captures you have to
otherwise the queen hangs Bishop
captures and not Knight captures and C3
uh now you have given up The Rook for
the uh for the for the exchange but you
now have the past C pawn and it's very
easy to to just push those pawns forward
we have Rook B to C1 Now Pawn to A5 it's
very hard to handle this night the
Knight is guarded by the bishop and the
two Rooks and queen are helpless against
this Knight with Bishop to G5 now trying
to get rid of this knight uh B4 by
Magnus with Bishop to D2 now comes Rook
to d8 putting uh even putting pressure
on that Bishop here born to H4 by
Vincent and now Rook to D3 just the
absolute control here by Magnus with
Ponte H5 and now Magnus could just
continue pushing here but he even plays
G captures an H5 much like an engine
would so be Bishop captures and C3
Bishop captures attacks The Rook here
and now the problem is there's no good
way to to handle this one one nice idea
would be Rook to E5 point is that if now
Bishop captures an E5 you can play Rook
captures on D3 but still C captures Rook
captures on C6 Now Pawn to D2 uh you you
cannot play Rook to C1 you cannot play
Rook to D6 to stop the pass Pawn you're
gonna have to play checking G7 and now
play Rook to d8 but still Bishop C3 and
just defends the pass Pawn they're gonna
play a for B3 create another pass pawn
and I easily win this so uh not a lot of
good ideas for this Rogue Vincent tries
Queen to E2 uh Queen to E2 is much
better it's it's a very tricky move by
Vincent because if not Magnus captures
The Rook on E1 then Vincent can play
Queen captures on D3 and it's gonna be
very tricky for example see captors Rook
captures on C6 Pawn to D2 now you can
play Rook to D6 and now uh White is in
time to stop those pawns King F1 B3
captures characters captures and King to
E2 this is the key move and now after B2
you can play Rook B6 and both B1 and D1
are covered so uh very nicely done by
Vincent playing this uh Queen T2 idea
but Magnus of course ignores The Rook he
just plays Queen to D5 now gains full
control over the D file and Vincent will
have to really really figure out how to
go about this position so he goes Queen
to E8 with check King G7 and now Rook
the E3 he has to try something but just
Pawn to H6 Magnus improves his position
a little bit with Queen to E4 offering a
queen trade and now Magnus very very
happily trades Queen captures Rook
captures and now just Pawn to B3
creating a pass by on here Rook
characters on C4 and now B captures an
A2 of course you cannot go after the
bishop as A1 will Queen so Rook to A4
and now of course A1 Queen Magnus goes
into a rook and pawn end game but he's
up to pawns and for Magnus that is that
that is more than enough we have Rook C
captures on A1 Bishop captures an A1
Rook captures and now Rook to D5 but
even though uh this is winning for black
you still have to play very very precise
uh moves to win this so of course
Vincent will do his best to defend this
Rook to A4 not allowing anything to
cross the fourth Rank and now it's time
to activate the king king F6 magnus's
first idea is to bring the king over
here and start advancing the pawn so
King to F1 King to E6 with King to E2
now Rook the F5 stopping the king from
going any further to the queen side as
the F1 would hang so F3 and now King to
D6 by Magnus but now Vincent plays Rook
to C4 stops the king from advancing any
further and and the Magnus now goes for
Rook to C5 Rook to G5 forcing white to
deal with the g-pawn might be a slight
Improvement here uh sort of uh forcing
the white king to lose a bit activity
but Magnus of course knows what he's
doing Rook C5 uh Rook the F4 now goes
after the pawn here and Rook the E5 with
check King D3 and now F5 would be a big
mistake here if you play F5 then you
start losing uh the pawns along the H
file so King E6 and now Vincent just
goes back Rook to A4 he says your idea
of bringing the king over is not going
to work so find something else and
Magnus says okay I'm gonna find
something else so King to F6 we have
Rook there for which check Magnus goes
King to G6 and Rook back to a for
Vincent is very happy with everything
being as it is uh Rook the G5 now going
after the pawn rotate to events and
defends it Rook to E5 and now again Rook
the A4 Vincent holds this uh Ponta F6
and now uh Vincent has to figure out how
to continue playing this and he plays
Spawn to G3 uh which is weird because if
this defense works why why spoil it the
problem is it doesn't really work
because if you play now a move let's say
Rook to A3 uh then H4 is coming and the
problem is now if you just repeat go
after the age Pawn here
uh King to H5 and now if you try to
repeat again Rook day two Rook to G5 now
you can't move the Rook back because the
G2 Pawn hangs King to E3 now you play A4
and now you have a problem here yeah if
Rook captures any four Rook captures on
G2 it creates a past H Pawn and if you
play King to F2 first then Rook to A5
and this is how you continue making
progress okay Rook day three blocks the
pawn and then uh you you uh well now you
control the G3 square and now probably
the idea is to bring the king over well
not that square but uh over to B4 and
start advancing the pawn uh promote the
pawn win the white rook and then you
will be hopefully faster than than the
white pawns here but yeah it is winning
so after F6 G3 by Vincent he tries
something else but now Rook G5 attacks
the pawn and King to E3 he wants to give
up the G3 Pawn for the A5 pawn and
Magnus goes for it Rook captures on G3
Rook captures an a 5 and now you have to
start advancing the pass Pawn if you
don't uh Vincent will be in time to stop
it pawn to H4 we have rooked the A8 and
down uh you don't want to rush it if H3
Rook to G8 blunders the game so you have
to be careful Magnus goes King to H5
with King to F2 and now Rook to G6 uh
just preparing to move the the pawn The
Rook is now cutting off the king from
the G file Rook A5 check we have Rook to
G5 and now Rook to A3 we have Pawn to H3
advancing the pawn Ponta F4 attacking
the rook and now again you have to be
careful if H2 here if you want to be
Hasty uh just a rook the H3 check and
again you will not be able to win this
uh King G4 Rook chapters and H2 Rook H5
and this is not much more than a draw
now so instead after F4 Magnus just
plays Rook the G2 check and he was in
this position and move 65 that uh
Vincent kaimer resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
the problem is whatever you do here
let's say King to F3 uh King H4 and now
if Rook to A4 you're just gonna play
Rook the G3 check King F2 H2 and uh it
doesn't really matter F5 check is met
with Rook to G4 so nothing is happening
here and if you block with Rook to A1 uh
even the blunt Rook to G1 is enough to
win the game now you are threatening
promotion and if white wins this Pawn of
course which is uh the only thing uh to
do uh a king will capture an F4 and now
you have a clean King and pawn end game
with black being up to Pawns of course
this is completely winning so yeah after
Rook to G2 Magnus uh nicely wins the
game uh and uh he uh gains uh again some
raiding approaches uh uh gets a step
closer to that 2900 rating uh he drew
his first game against Lavon Aryan and
won his game against Vincent now so he's
I guess up like one one point maybe like
2860. so he's he's getting there but he
did mention that he is putting his
unattainable goal
um sort of on pause so he's not really
focused on that but you know what else
is he going to focus on that pretty much
the only thing he has left to achieve uh
so I'm sure it's uh you know somewhere
amongst amongst his goals uh but yeah
it's a very very hard uh where Vincent
went wrong actually I mean it's uh
incredibly difficult to pinpoint
um
the mistake in this game that caused the
Vincent to lose it was just uh uh all
the way from the beginning like every
move it's like it's like not every move
that Vincent made Magnus made a move
that was uh you know a little bit better
than Vincent's move it's like Vincent
plays the the second best move by the
injured Magnus plays the top move by the
engine and after some 20 or 30 moves you
know the event the advantages just pile
up and uh I mean you've made no mistakes
you've pretty much played every move an
engine move but your position is no
longer uh manageable
so really wild stuff a great game by
Magnus uh taking a full point from from
a spectacular player like like Vincent
kymer like it's a second place in the
world rapid Championship behind Magnus
that is absolutely spectacular and even
in classical he's definitely a beast to
be to be reckoned with but Magnus uh I
was able to take this one with the black
pieces uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it now in round three
we have the absolute Clash we have the
clash of the 2800s Magnus costume will
face dinglieren uh and uh I mean anyone
uh it could be a it could be a quick
draw like
it's anyone's guess but it could also be
like the two of them have plates so
complicated classical games uh that no
amount of time with the engine will help
you uh solve what what they just did so
we'll see what happens but I'm very much
looking forward to that game uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
the story about a bit of a longer video
but it is classical chess and these guys
are really exceptional so we have to
explore some additional lines uh I mean
it is classical chess uh I would like to
thank randomfile.net the Jimbo Robert
Kiefer deutron and ravishing reptiles
YouTube for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Tata steel uh until it
finishes uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day uh probably next game I'm showing
will be ding Carson unless it will be a
a complete snooze Fest see you soon